dived at the downs of today
yes why don't you like the wire by the
tariffs against China now
I'm not concerned about that at all I
expected that a little bit because
people don't understand quite yet about
what's happened we've tax China on three
hundred billion dollars worth of goods
and products being sold into our country
and China eats it because they have to
pay it because what they do is they
devalue their currency and they push
money out our people haven't paid as you
know we're also charging them 25 percent
on two hundred and fifty billion dollars
so we're taking in many billions of
dollars there's been absolutely no
inflation and frankly it hasn't cost our
consumer or anything it costs China now
what has happened is a lot of companies
are moving out of China so they can have
you know avoid and China's had a rough
twenty this is their worst year in 27
years according to yesterday's Wall
Street Journal I don't want that but
when my people came home they said we're
talking we have another meeting in early
September I said that's fine but in the
meantime until such time as there's a
deal
we'll be taxing them we're just getting
and we're getting very good numbers from
the border the twenty-one thousand
soldiers supplied by Mexico and I want
to thank Mexico they're doing a great
job the numbers are way down at the
border
I think it's very much under control
very much under control well what would
you say it is let me ask you a question
right right right right sure sure what
would you say when China for the last 20
years has been taken hundreds of
billions of dollars out of our country
and we had a president that would never
do anything a number of presidents that
never would do anything about it what
would you say for many years China has
been taking money out by the hundreds of
billions of dollars a year we have
rebuilt China so now it's time that we
change thinking around if they don't
want to trade with us anymore that would
be fine with me would save a lot of
money no I don't know I think I think
President Xi who's somebody I like a lot
I think he wants to make a deal but
frankly he's not going fast enough he
said he was going to be buying from our
farmers he didn't do that he said he was
going to stop fentanyl from coming into
our country it's all coming out of China
he didn't do that we're losing thousands
of people defense at all and this was
time and very importantly for many years
you know this better than anybody you've
been covering it for a long time for
many years China has been taking out
hundreds of billions of dollars a year
and rebuilding China it's time that we
rebuild our country you know the one
thing I have to say and you have to say
this what China is doing is they're
devaluing their currency and they're
pumping money out like they've never
done before and they're paying for these
tariffs we're not
are you concerned by reports that the
Chinese army may be preparing to
intervene in Hong Kong against
demonstrators and what do you say to the
accusations of us well something's
probably happening with Hong Kong
because when you look at you know what's
going on they've had riots for a long
period of time and I don't know what
China's attitude is somebody said that
at some point they're going to want to
stop that but that's between Hong Kong
and that's between China because Hong
Kong is a part of China they'll have to
deal with that themselves they don't
need advice no no no no September one
the reason is it takes a long time for
the ships to come over and it's a period
of time so I'm giving up for of like a
four week period of time before the
tariffs go on but we're now taking in
tariffs on 10% on over 300 billion and
25% on two hundred and fifty billion and
it's been proven that our people in that
Bank for those terrors
short-range missiles we never made an
agreement on that I have no problem
we'll see what happens but these are
short-range missiles they're very
standard go ahead what go ahead
congressman Ratcliffe is an outstanding
man and I'm sure that he'll be able to
do very well I think he's just
outstanding highly respected by
everybody that does we've not changed on
well way we're not allowing Huawei into
our country we're not changed on that we
can do business for non security things
with Huawei because that's you know
we'll do that but anything having to do
with national security we're not dealing
with Huawei what do you think about the
decision to not prosecute James Comey
for legal well I haven't actually heard
that I know there's a lot of things
going on that's a piece of it I guess
but I really don't know I haven't spoken
to them about that I would frankly be
surprised because what James Comey did
was illegal so I would be surprised but
I don't know anything about that
they begin chanting something
problematic I don't know what's going to
happen I can tell you this I'm going to
Cincinnati the arena is a very large one
and we've sold it out we could sell it
out probably ten times from what I hear
the the applications for seats as you
know never had an empty seat the
applications are very big I have no idea
we have a great group of people they
love our country they love the job we're
doing and when they see the kind of
people that want to represent us from
the last two nights that's not what they
want I don't know I can't tell you
whether or not they're going to do that
chance if they do the chant we'll have
to see what happens
well I don't know that you can't stop
people I don't know that you can I mean
we'll see what we can do I'd prefer that
they don't but if they do it we'll have
to make a decision then my message is
for the people of going to so we had
over a hundred thousand applications for
whatever the size of the I think it's a
fourteen thousand seat arena but we're
way over a hundred and I think one
hundred and twenty-two thousand
applications for those seats you know
what my message is I love them
and I think they love me I actually
think they love me
[Music]
have they accepted the offer or not well
that's up to it's really up to Prime
Minister Modi and I met with Prime
Minister Khan I got along great with I
think they're fantastic people Khan and
Modi I mean I would imagine they can get
along very well but if they wanted
somebody to intervene or to help them
and I spoke with Pakistan about that and
I spoke frankly in India about it but
that's been going on that battle for a
long time but if somebody if I can if
they wanted me to I would I would
certainly intervene yeah I can't come
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
which process are you talking about
because I felt that congressman
Ratcliffe was being treated very
unfairly I was reading the press and I
think I am a student of the press and I
could see that the press was treating
him I thought very unfairly he's an
outstanding man and I asked him I said
you want to go through this for two or
three months or would you want me to
maybe do something else and he thought
about it I said it's going to be rough I
could see exactly where the press is
going and fake news he's a fine he's a
fine man he's a fine man and so we
hadn't started the process and I thought
it's easier before we start but I read
things that were just unfair and he's
just too good he doesn't deserve it
little at what well that might be I like
sue Gordon and sue Gordon is there now
and I like her very much I've always
liked sue court it could be yeah it
could be we'll make another choice and
Sue will be she's there now and and
certainly she will be considered for the
acting and that could happen we'll
probably be talking about it either
later today or next week they're like
sue Gordon no I think he was just
treated very badly very harshly by the
press and he really had a decision to
make you want to go through this for it
could be months and I said I think I see
exactly what they're trying to do I
nobody understands the press but I think
I understand him as well as anybody and
I didn't think it was fair
know that it I I think he would have had
support but again we were very early in
the process we hadn't even started so we
were very early in the process and I
think he would have had good support
certainly from the Republicans you what
I haven't seen that I can tell you the
Democrats with Chile that's for sure but
the Republicans I think would have been
very good but a lot of the Republicans
didn't know John but I think he would
have had good receptivity and he was
getting that but I believe he made the
right decision
you understand
well now you bet for me I like when you
vet no no you vet I think the White
House is a great vetting process you've
that for me when I give a name I give it
out to the press and you bet for me a
lot of times you do a very good job not
always
I think the vet with the white if you
look at it I mean if you take a look at
it the vetting process for the White
House is very good but your part of the
vetting process you know I give out a
name to the press and they vet for me we
save a lot of money that way but in the
case of John I really believe that he
was being treated very harshly and very
unfairly
no I tell you what I think he would have
had very good support the Republicans
love John Ratcliffe and I think he would
have had very good support now he wasn't
in that world that much I think he would
have picked it up very quickly but I
think he would have had great Republican
support probably would have had no
Democrat support which would have been
nice to get some but I think he would
have done fine but it would have been
along it would have been a long hard
slog
[Music]
well that's okay I don't mind that the
tweet itself was just really a repeat of
what I heard over the news I know his
house was robbed and I thought that was
too bad that was really just that was
really not meant as a wise guy tweet I
mean his house was robbed and it came
over the news at a certain moment last
night and I had just mentioned
[Music]
well I think John and number one you
have to understand we are so far behind
we have been treated so badly and I
don't blame China I blame our past
leaders up as presidents our past
straight representatives they've done a
terrible job China we can't just go and
make it even deal with China we have to
make a much better deal with China
because right now they have a very
unfair playing field and I'm turning it
around so we're getting 25 percent of
250 billion dollars and now we'll be
getting 10% of probably close to 350
billion dollars it's a lot of money
China has to do a lot of things to turn
it around but you'll be seeing they've
got to do a lot of things it goes on on
September 1st and frankly if they don't
do them I can always increase it very
substantially in other words I could
increase it if I wanted to I could
increase it to a very much higher number
well it's in a process right now I know
the case very well it's a very sad
situation it really it's heartbreaking
but that's in a process right now so I'm
not going to get involved in the process
as you know they're going to be making a
final decision I guess over the next 10
days so I won't interfere with the
process say it well we've been moving it
down we've been moving it down from
Syria we defeated the Isis Caliphate and
we have now a hundred percent of that we
have two thousand five hundred prisoners
and Europe is going to have to take them
where somebody's going to have to take
them but we have 2,500 Isis prisoners
and we've told Europe hey some come from
France some from come from Germany and
they're gonna have to take them so we'll
see what happens but we've pretty much
reduced so we've taken it way down in
Syria ultimately it'll be down to a very
few people if any with respect to
Afghanistan we've made a lot of progress
we're talking but we've also made a lot
of progress we're reducing it we've been
there for 19 years we're really serving
as policemen we could win Afghanistan in
two days or three days or four days if
we wanted but I'm not looking to kill
ten million people
what about it we could win that war very
easily I could win that war in a week if
I wanted to but I'm not looking to kill
ten million people okay
many of them would be innocent people
I'm not looking to do and I'm not
talking nuclear by the way I'm talking
totally conventional but I'm not looking
to kill millions of people in
Afghanistan that I can't tell you I mean
you know we'll find out
well I hear he's done a good job I don't
know congressman hurt but I've heard
he's done a good job we differ on
certain subjects but I've heard he's
actually done a good job it's too bad
he's leaving but we really don't know
him so I do have a short list I have a
list of a few people we're looking at
very well-known people people where the
vetting would go very easily because
that's what they've been doing there in
the intelligence world so we do have a
list of three people that I'm going to
be working on over the weekend we're
going to vet Minster I'll be working on
that over the weekend and probably on
Monday I'll give you an answer and I do
like sue Gordon very much is acting as
your pest for you
say it again well I think we really I
think we have a lot of good people we
have three people specifically I mean I
could tell you I can tell you they're
right here right there but it's too it's
too early you want a piece of the lesson
well I don't want to say if they can be
trusted or not left history I would say
it's not so good but they don't like us
much either but we brought them down we
brought the the number of soldiers down
very substantially they're coming down
we are talking to them we have a lot of
advantages making a deal with us we're
doing very well as you know with
Pakistan I met a gentleman who I'd liked
a lot as you know last week from
Pakistan I have a lot of respect for we
have a good friendship I could a good
feeling good chemistry and I think
Pakistan will help us and I think others
will get involved but we've been there
19 years we're not really let's put it
this way we're more policemen than
anything else and that's not for our
soldiers and I've said I've said it a
lot we could win the war in fact we
could win the war if you look at it and
you could look at it any way you want we
could win the war in Afghanistan in less
than a week but I'm not looking to kill
ten million people and I'm not talking
nuclear I'm not talking nuclear but
would win that war in less than a week
and I have that as an option always but
that's what we're not looking for
[Music]
so with Russia we have been speaking to
Russia about that about a pact for
nuclear so that they get rid of some we
get rid of some would probably have to
put China in there but right now we're
number one Russia's number two and
China's number three but China is quite
a bit down in terms of nuclear China's
much lower but we would certainly want
to include China at some point but I
would think that the relationship is
good we're trying to have a good
relationship it's very hard in light of
the phony witch-hunt which is now dead
but I will say this with Russia if we
could get a pact where they reduce and
we reduce nuclear that would be a great
thing for the world
and I do believe I do believe that will
happen we've done we have discussed it
I've also discussed it with China I've
discussed it with President Putin
I've also discussed it with China and I
will tell you China was very very
excited about talking about it and so is
Russia so I think we'll have a deal at
some point but the particular pact
you're talking about that expired as of
today they weren't living up to their
commitment and I said if they're not
going to live up to their commitment
then we have two more we always have to
be in the lead you know I've redone our
nuclear we have new nuclear coming I
hate to tell that to people I hate to
say it because it's devastating but
we've always got to be in the lead
hopefully and hope to god you never have
to use
say it
we have new everything we have them we
have the finest military in the world we
make the finest equipment in the world
by far whether it's fighters whether
it's whether it's missiles
whether it's the ships whether it's
submarines is nobody to compete with us
but if we could hold off spending by
getting a pact with Russia and with
China that would be very good for that
would be very good for all three
countries you're talking about the trade
with the one beef
[Music]
EU is very tough to deal with there you
know they're very difficult they have
barriers they have barriers on beef we
broke that barrier today I appreciate it
it's a group of countries as you know we
love those countries but for dealing
with them they're very very difficult
but we did a very big deal today beef
and we're going to be selling them a big
percentage of their beef and that's
great for our ranchers and farmers so we
were happy to do it
Otto Otto tariffs are never off the
table if they would not treat us fairly
which they dot I mean you know it's
right now look the EU has tremendous
barriers to us but we just broke the
first barrier and maybe we broke it
because of the fact that if I don't get
what we want
I'll put Auto tariffs because it's all
about the automobile and it's all about
the tariffs if I don't get it
get what I want I'll have no choice but
maybe to do that but so far they've been
very good and I want to thank Mexico the
numbers are way way down apprehensions
the numbers are way down Mexico they
have about 21,000 they actually now have
maybe more than that on our border they
have another 6,000 on their northern
border okay you view it that way their
northern border near Guatemala and I
will tell you Mexico's doing a great job
well I would love to see before we talk
about secretary I will tell you I would
love to see the Democrat sit down and
work out the loopholes in 20 minutes
because that's what it would take and
work out asylum but we're moving along
with an asylum fix an asylum bill
Lindsey Graham is heading it up very
capably and we'll see what happens
I'll always help our farmers our farmers
were targeted by China and our farmers
frankly these are great Patriots I'll
always help our farmers there'll be a
time when the biggest beneficiary of
what I'm doing with respect to China and
trade generally you seeing it with the
EU they couldn't do the cattle thing at
all beef they couldn't do it at all and
now all of a sudden this came out of
nowhere
our farmers will ultimately be the
biggest beneficiary and they know that
but our farmers are great Patriots
[Music]
now what happens is China devalues their
currency and China also is pouring money
out and that will pay for the tariffs
it's a total misnomer now I don't say
that with all countries but with China
they're very highly sophisticated but so
are we more than anybody would
understand all you have to do is answer
China all you have to do is ask China
but but let me just explain so China is
devaluing their currency and they're
also pouring money in their currencies
going to hell but they're also pouring
money in and that will totally pay for
the Paris the tariffs are not being paid
for by our people it's being paid for by
China because of devaluation and because
they're pumping money in thank you
[Music]
while you interview the wrong farmer
number one number two any amount that
China sucks out we're making up out of
the billions of dollars that would take
it in remember this our countries take
it in billions and billions of dollars
from China we never took in 10 cents
from China and out of that many billions
of dollars we're taking a part of it and
we're giving it to the farmers because
they've been targeted by China the
farmers they come out totally home so
you interviewed the rough farmer
[Applause]
[Music]